straight straight to the point
so um ladies and gents um
we're going to start off with an article
from the guardian okay i'm going to read
this article and it says this
the office for national statistics
shows that women not living in a couple
who have never been married
is rising
in every age range under under 70.
in the in in the decade and a half
between two
2002 sorry to 2018 the figure for those
aged 40 to 70 rolls by half a million
the percentage of never married
singletons in their 40s doubled there is
no avoiding that our romantic
opportunities have dwindled as the pool
of age-appropriate men has been emptied
this is what a woman's now saying
annually we manage a small smattering of
dates between us
most of us have grown weary of online
dating which requires you to treat it as
an all-consuming hobby or a part-time
job we are tired of tinder bored of
bumble i have been ejected by e-harmony
which i last time last time i logged on
told me i could they could not find me a
single match
oh wow they couldn't find her a single
match what a lady in the guardian said
she they were interviewing her i wonder
what she looks like yeah how much do you
weigh
she's probably a whale yes
[Laughter]
so ladies what do we think what do we
think of
the dating scene right now and
are modern women becoming more lonely
um
okay i was in a five-year relationship
which means i was 23 when i got into it
and i was 28 when i came out i'm not 29.
when i came out i decided to join hinge
and tinder because i was dealing with 24
25 year old men
and now i'm dealing with men that plus
30 plus so i want to know what the new
kind of pool of dating feels like and to
be honest
it's not good
i feel like people are too
focused on the the superficial it
doesn't go deep enough and that's why
people don't trust each other it's not
just because women are turning bad it
goes both ways so yeah it's messed up
right now for real i agree with that
yeah
i've never been to any uh dating sites
and everything and every time i date
someone i have to meet them face to face
like you know from friends to friends
and like all my exes i never found them
like any social media or um you know i
mean probably yeah not social media but
it's more likely like i've met them in
real life instead of actually being on a
dating app and everything our stories
are quite similar me and denova so i was
also in a relationship for five years
and i've never been the same as angel
i've never been on a dating website and
when that relationship ended i didn't
think to go straight to a dating website
i just stepped outside i did it for
research purposes by the way
you think i have problems finding a man
thank you yeah probably but go on ah
if you see the roster is long
no anyone it's just way in okay well i
think um there's two things i think our
society is very um
we live in a world with social media and
we live in a world with a lot of
distraction and i think people are under
the illusion that people are replaceable
and are very much addicted to the
dopamine hit of meeting someone new and
the infatuation but the minute it gets
difficult oh well there's someone i can
swipe on tinder and they'd want to go
out with me kind of thing and i think
also too in in
in society i think men
have they know what women want they know
what women need and i don't think it's
the other way around
i would agree with that so you would say
that men know what women want but women
don't know what men want yeah i think
like
in my in my experience like
women at my age they were told oh
um you are perfect just the way you are
and you don't need to settle for anyone
less than you deserve
and so
i think
and so
i think
it leads people astray
and the question is what do you deserve
you deserve what you get and that's
something we don't tell women i know i
think you deserve it i think you deserve
like
someone on your level and i think i
think women with social media and stuff
if you if you like post a picture with
your butt out or even if you just post a
photoshop photo or just a photo of
yourself and your instagram is public
you can get thousands of them sorry i
mean i mean get like commitment wise
oh like so i'm saying like girls deserve
what they can get commitment-wise but if
i say i deserve to be a millionaire and
i don't get millionaire outcomes then i
probably don't deserve to be a
millionaire
that's too far that's why
what that's too far as well to be able
to oh yeah i deserve that much but like
i feel like most women just want um a
lot of respect as well from their
partner more like and you know get um
you know gestures and all these romantic
things when you're in a relationship
what i'm talking about and i feel like
nowadays it's really hard to find
a man
that would do that because of how the
world is at the moment you know our
generation that's just you know as what
you said social media and all these
things it just distract
a lot of men fully because they like a
lot of men follow women on instagram
because obviously they find these
females attractive and all these things
and that kind of messes up how they
think about females too so when they
turn up um when they china
uh i don't know if a girl if they're
dating our females if they're dating a
girl it's really hard for them to like
focus on that one person because there's
so many things in on social media that's
only i would say that's only a small
percentage of men because most men don't
have the options to focus on other girls
so like like on um dating apps women
only swipe right five percent of the
time where men swipe right 50 percent of
the time
and like one out of one out of three men
one on one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year
yeah so so those you know i'm saying
like those guys like they're not you
would be the center of their world but
we don't want those guys like for
example if you want a guy that's over
six foot you know i'm looking at my tall
you know
yeah which same but that's but that's
only 15 of men and if you want to be
good looking cut that in half if you
want to make money cut that in half if
you want and if you want if you want
them to have a similar personality like
charismatic cut that in half so that's
it's like two percent of guys we're all
fighting over so then
you see why do you see why i'm asking
the question
do modern women want cats or dogs
because you're going to be lonely
because if you if you are fighting in a
pool of men
that only a certain amount there's only
a certain amount of those top tier men
that women want but 80 of women
generally list 20 of men when they ask
for their ideal man right so if there's
20 of men who have an 80 pool of women
to choose from that will leave at least
what 60 of women without a partner
however
those women continue to fight for that
top 20 man and that's one of the reasons
why a lot of women say men are trash men
are dogs mad at this because they are
fighting for the same men well and half
of those guys don't commit to anyone why
would you right why why would you when
you have that matter
like drake was drake gonna get a wife no
but i think it goes back to what you
were saying about how the women even
know what they want anyway in the first
place no no that's not what i said i
said do women know what men want
okay
oh we want to know that's a good
question
because it's instilled in men like go
get a job make sure you can accumulate
as much resources as possible so that
you can find the best looking woman or
best woman you can
but
like a lot of women don't know what
genuinely satisfies a man i know in my
experience in the past i just thought
like i was told to date who i want to be
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible